من هنا من اهميه هذه المنطقه من كوبيانسكا
التي اتواجد فيها والتي باتت احد المحاور
الرئيسيه للقتال في كل هذه المنطقه
الشرقيه
عمليا كوبيانك باتت محطه الانظار يمكنك ان
تشاهد حجم الدمار حجم القصف الروسي
المستمر الذي يلحق بهذه المدينه بشكل يومي
لماذا كوبياس لانها اصبحت المركز الرئيسي
والمحور الرئيسي للهجوم الروسي على طول
هذه الجبهه لاسيما الممتده من خاركاف
لوجانسك عمليا موقع مدينه كوبيانسكو موقع
استراتيجي هو يقع بين مقاطعتين بين لوجانس
وبين خركات تحاول من خلالها القوات
الروسيه التي كانت قد خسرت سيطرتها على
هذه المدينه في سبتمبر الماضي تحاول ان
تستعيدها مجددا لذلك الوجود هنا في هذه
المنطقه يكتسب اهميه كبيره من خلال
التاكيد وفق هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
بانها ما زالت تسي على مدينه كوبيانك هذا
من جهه وانها تقوم برد كل العمليات
العسكريه ومحاولات التقدم التي تقوم بها
القوات الروسيه على هذا المحور عمليا ضمن
المقاطعات الشرقيه ما يحصل حاليا محاولات
تقدم روسيه في كوبيانسك من هذه المنطقه
التي اتواجد فيها ولمان في المقابل القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول ان تتقدم في منطقه
باخموت ولكن عمليا بالنسبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه هي تسعى ان لا تسقط هذه
المدينه مجددا بايدي القوات الروسيه كي لا
تشكل امرين الامر الاول محاوله ضغط
والتفاف من هذه المنطقه باتجاه دونياتك
والمناطق التي ما زالت تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه وتقدر بنحو 30% من من مقاطعه
دانياش والامر الثاني يرتبط بمحاوله تامين
وحمايه القوات الروسيه المتواجده في
مقاطعه لوغاس لذلك هذه المنطقه باتت محور
كل الاشتباكات وكل محاوله التقدم والتراجع
بين الطرفين